on this episode we talk slime everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 301 of the askgaryvee show and
I'm super excited about this episode
because it's gonna touch on a lot of
things that I'm passionate about
families and entrepreneurship and youth
culture trends and so without further
ado I have two lovely guests here and
I'm gonna allow them to introduce
themselves hi I'm Maddy I'm a slime
entrepreneur and where do you live Maddy
Fairfield Connecticut and how old are
you 13 years old and when did you start
your slime entrepreneurship career I
started slime in 2016
got it and was it first just hobby and
then it became more entrepreneurial it
started when my friends brought slime to
school so it was more just for fun and
then it became a business and a hobby
awesome we'll get into that in a little
bit and you sir I'm her father
Howard greats fan yes and I actually
make slime too but not yeah so let's
let's set this up for everybody who's
listening and watching obviously we
touched on it for a second to uh you
know obviously the there's also slime
bash and actually let's start let's
start that way and I'll go backwards
what for everybody who's listening what
is what is a slime bash so slime bash is
the first ever slime convention it's
actually sparked a trend of hundreds to
even thousands of sign conventions all
over the world
it's basically where people can have a
booth and they can sell slime they can
meet their internet friends trade slime
and have a great time and and how long
has that been going on since May May
around then and then we may have this
year was the first one and where was
that that was in Stamford Connecticut
understood and since then you've had how
many two
and the last one was in Mohican Sun yes
and there are a couple coming up yes we
have Sun Bosch Daytona Florida and then
we have a slime bath Chicago and that's
in January yes January and March love it
and so you'll be traveling to these
things
yes so are you guys planning and
navigating around school schedule like
what's going on with that stuff
definitely so like you have school today
in theory right yes that being this
podcast was worth a missed school day
listen for everybody's watching as you
can imagine I'm aware of the slime trend
my daughter got into it but more
importantly even if she hadn't I spent
so much time looking at what's popping
in culture and the Internet and no
question slime has been an amazing
phenomenon for you no excuse female but
plenty of kids boys are into it as well
skews young but it I keep watching it
get younger and older it's super
interesting because unlike baseball
cards which was really my version of
conventions and going to boots and
selling and meeting people what's
amazing is people are making the product
if you are completely lost on this just
Google around you'll be blown away by
the capabilities and creativity of the
marketplace so let's take a step back
like it's funny I think about what grade
are you in eighth grade awesome so so
what in sixth grade is when it you first
saw it yes and so literally as simple as
and in my fifth grade year the the it's
funny you bring it up when you were
saying how it went down it made me think
of Garbage Pail Kids there was this
thing called Garbage Pail Kids way back
in a day and in fifth grade it
completely took over our school
completely took over our school oh yeah
it's right there it's that little thing
that's that's that's geeky Gary uh it
completely took over our school and it
literally happened as simple as one kid
came in you know to school in fifth
grade and had them and then like
complete hysteria were you early on the
slime trend in sixth grade like the
group like your friends came in and had
it and you get on quick and then they
everybody get into it how what
percentage of the girls in your class
got into it all that go well it started
when my friend brought a ton of slime to
school she pretty much filled her entire
backpack with slime and everyone would
go to her locker
take some slime and we just play with it
during class and I knew teachers let
that happen at first they did now not so
much thing but yeah and was and had you
known about had you've seen videos had
you known anything about slime prior to
this girl bringing slime to school no I
wasn't allowed to have Instagram then
yeah I didn't even really know what
slime was yep and so did you love it
immediately um or is it just like
whatever I mean it was really just
whatever I thought it was and I thought
it was kind of weird I thought it was
cool I didn't really understand the
creativity behind it yep and now you can
kind of make it your own I thought it
was just a basic white slime and that
was it got it and so when did it build
and how did it build in your mind um I
think in like December of 2016 I started
to make it I got into the trend and then
I begged my parents to get me let me use
a slime Instagram mm-hmm and then I was
like what are you could ensue mean
content on YouTube um I think I was
mostly Instagram that now it's sort of
moving into YouTube mm-hmm but it's
mostly Instagram so how do you know like
how do you make your first lime you want
your friends and you were watching
how-to videos or like how did it go down
I was watching how-to videos pretty much
the YouTube like slime videos were just
like how to make basic fluffy slime or
like detergent or borax mm-hmm but now
it's sort of like a creativity thing
like slime reviews on YouTube there's
like slime challenges there's a ton of
new stuff yeah see it I mean it's
although the trend is evolving quite a
bit where do you think slime it is in
its cultural like progression like do
you think slimes gonna be as popular in
three years do you think it's gonna go
up and down like what's your gut and I
know it's a very difficult question it's
difficult for anybody but just your
opinion on where are we right now are we
the height do you see it slowing down is
it picking up momentum what's your take
um I definitely do see people leaving
the community the slime community on
Instagram just they're getting tired of
it but there are people who are really
evolving their business there's new
trends like every day there's a new
slime trend or a new video trend what's
the current like for what's the hot
thing right now in slime it's changing
your containers okay you put this Simon
so there's now these like flat oval
containers rather than like yeah yeah
but they're they're flat okay instead of
being like larger and taller yep and
those are like the new trends now that's
what everybody likes yes bling the bling
in the containers the packaging really
is really popular what's your favorite
part as of this second obviously what's
so amazingly interesting to me about
young entrepreneurs is when you're in
sixth grade like when you're in eighth
grade your life is evolving very quickly
not only your business and so your
things that you think are cool and
things that you're interested in are
moving very fast and so I'm always
fascinated by that for you at this point
is it about the making is about the
creativity is it about building a
business with your dad like what what is
like the best part currently of the
whole slime thing well I like that I can
I like the creativity aspect definitely
I like how slime is a product and you
can make it however you'd like it's sort
of the design aspect to like I can
design packaging I can design the slime
the label everything yep so you still
love making it yes that's awesome
yeah jump in here and speak to the
parents of young entrepreneurs and
trends and more importantly before we
even get into they're like the macro of
it all I'd love to know a little bit
about your backstory like you
professionally when did this first say
like give me the whole narrative what do
you do when did it first hit your radar
and how did things evolve with you guys
together okay well I'd like to think I'm
an active dad my business background is
you know I went to school for business
was in marketing a product development
and
I have very similar entrepreneurial
aspects that used to sell baseball cards
myself you know back when I was a little
team where'd you grow up in Connecticut
love it used to do the shows are you a
new york-based sportsman or Boston based
sports New York base it's a very weird
place yeah New York definitely yeah I
was definitely leaning down do you like
the Patriots cause if you do your
daughter and you have to get out of my
office
that's exactly where that was going good
so um you know and right now my company
makes a lot of products so when I
remember the day when Madison or Maddie
came over sorry um when Maddie came and
and it's ray your middle name yes
understood
so Maddie came to me and said let's go
look for you know glue and everybody was
sold out and I'm like I don't know what
to tell you Maddie and she says well can
we just make it and can I make it and
that was how it all started way back
when can I make glue mm-hmm that's a
great question 20:19 you know and you
know it's and how to make glue after
yeah so from a from a parent perspective
you know it's wonderful working with
whether doing anything with you what
happened next I apologize to jump to
bring me back so she comes I don't know
what happens you found some glue
somewhere or you started trying to meet
glue um well we sourced it in China yeah
you would you went hardcore yeah I'm
like let's cut everybody out well they
don't they don't have really a glue
industry in the United States yeah to go
overseas but you're talking about real
volume yeah like you know the normal
person that's listening they went bought
a couple Elmer's and they made some
slime do you know if you're going direct
to China you're talking about scale yeah
well how quickly did it go from like
Maddie right from you like being like I
want to make slime too like did you want
to sell slime right away I did I didn't
really know what that really meant but
you did right I love that excited me
like that is my childhood everything was
about selling something so it's just an
entrepreneurial trait like like so many
I know I you know I don't want to put a
lot of you don't mention a lot of young
kids so but I know 15 girls that like
making slime zero of them want to sell
it I desperately tried
but you wanted to sell right away I did
I didn't really know how to make a
website or anything so it did take me a
while and were you thinking that way
were you thinking make sell on the
Internet Instagram account not I'm gonna
sling this in school yes did you think
you'd get some sales in school or you
didn't want to mix your business with
your social life I mean I had friends
who are already selling it at school so
I didn't really think that that was a
good idea Tom you didn't want it you
didn't want to get into like the
emotions of you didn't want a
competitive business environment to
destroy friendships yes no that's super
smart I get it okay so so what happened
it went really like you she was like
when she came to you or when I hit your
radar was it very much in the beginning
or did you or did she have interest you
saw her making some you know I didn't
really know it was gonna be anything
right yeah of course but I thought it
was a good education for her yeah pumped
about that you know she does all you
know she was we started having board
meetings every week so what so he was
bouncing her little bit so he comes to
you and immediate it's like dad I want
to start a slime business and you're
like let's do this together
well she said that you know I don't
really make I don't make slime I said
make a little bit now I've heard my Tom
it's not very great but she wanted it
you know she wanted to you know talk
about glue and you know consumer
products or what I do what my company
does and I thought it was a great
opportunity to do it do that aspect
together god and she so the thought was
just because I'm putting pieces together
maybe start a glue brand and sell butt
glue cos glue was starting to dry up
well the idea was that you're a parent
at the beginning of the glue phase in
the slime phase and there was Elmer's
and other products but I remember when
we first started we bought rubber cement
we didn't know what glue works so if you
have slime glue it takes the guesswork
out of shore herons and that's where it
all started and now she's developed so
many different products in the glue
field and the slime field and the
accessory field and is that selling on
Shopify in Amazon or like what's
happening with your products we sell it
on slime making comm and Amazon got it
and is that Shopify or what are you
using on the back end on the batteries
in the it's
jellify and Amazon
and who's doing the fulfillment when
they buy it directly from your website
the well most things are gonna run the
siphon through Amazon but got it
understood uh and how's that experience
been good you've learned a lot yes
definitely I learned how to run a
business which do you think that that's
something you're gonna want to do
eventually um are you not sure yet I
don't really think I want to own a
business with products but I definitely
would run a rip on to run my own
business love it so what happens next
like so this starts at first that you
don't think it's gonna be that big and
how quickly did you say holy crap
there's like a whole universe of this
and this is a clearly fast-moving
emerging trend in society and has some
legs well I remember the we sat down all
of us including Maddy and we're just
brainstorming about fun crazy ideas to
get people to know about her brand and I
and one of the things came up while we
break a world record and that is like
let's break a world record so you know
the team was like we can't do it and the
slogan be game we can do it so what
happened um well we did break the world
record was the record you went after the
world's largest slime loved it and what
was it at the time um there wasn't
actually a record right so you can start
here you tell you they tell you a
minimum yeah if there's nothing out
there they're gonna make something crazy
interesting so so there you're we're
talking Guinness Guinness this house
that's amazing so you held at one point
we're still holding Guinness Book of
World Records records you still hold it
or somebody got crazy and decided like
oh no no one's beat it yeah really you
whole so eight real quick you hold the
world record for the largest slime yes
which is thirteen thousand eight hundred
and twenty pounds where'd you put it
well we put it in a giant pool is really
crazy we had like hun we had a hundred
people just in the pool mixing this
slime with their hands and feet this is
that video online yes is it remarkable
like I gotta go check it out how how
many views is it AB um I mean we had a
lot of influencers there so every person
made a different video yeah but
one of our influencers had 20 million
views now there's a lot of different its
is it Keep Calm and blush on yeah that's
not the one yeah that's not our video
but amazing uh so what's the biggest
thing dad that you learned from this
experience for obviously knowing my
audience of this podcast there's a lot
of you listening right now what's what
are some your advice with your tips like
fight hasn't been fights has there been
arguments how's it gone what what has
made it work well I think you keep him
honest Manny I think for the most part
you know you kids are good the kids
today are incredible they can do
anything you know and I mean it's
amazing their learning capacity is so
much faster than adults they just have
so much more information at their
fingertips absolutely like like we could
have done this too bro but the problem
is we had Beckett baseball card guide
and I was the only information we had
yeah I learned Final Cut Pro in a month
and she lives in an hour a hundred
percent so I think it's a man I mean you
and I could have been friends I was in
Jersey or in Connecticut we could have
been baseball card friends but we didn't
have the technology stack called the
Internet to allow us to have that right
people's best friends are all over the
country now real quick stay on this for
a second I get a lot of pushback on
modern-day parenting and technology and
everybody talks about our kids are so
introverted they don't have social
skills and I keep arguing they have so
many friends in different places and are
more social they're just communicating
with a different device than meeting at
the mall at 4:30 at the arcade your
thoughts about that my parents would say
gosh we're watching too much TV
everything's always something with a
different age and our job as parents is
to understand it not just Mike Tyson's
punch-out I played unlimited so I get it
okay so our job is to encourage it to
understand it and to adapt and encourage
whatever they do
yes culture versus no culture yes I love
it
how's the events business like is this
super exciting it seems like it's
getting big yes it is
is it taxing its its head it's a it's a
it's a lot of work to throw events at
this scale that you guys just how many
people went to the Mohegan Sun one seven
thousand I mean it's you don't you
talking about a real business you know
like what do you how are you that guys
thinking about this right now
it's an enormous undertaking but as
people I think quote my little
six-year-old and I'm sure Madison that
he feels the same way the greatest
weekend of her life better than Disney
World we axed her she'd rather go to
Disney for slime bash and she said slime
fashion so awesome is she making slime
yes I love it is she good
she's six right yeah I mean she's a
slime snob like your reaction is you do
you have a high secret barrier to entry
to like being good it's like who you
know what let's give some love to the
community because I'm also where a lot
of the famous influencers you know drove
to kinetic I was I'm in the scene I have
a good sense who do you think is doing a
good job out there in making slime and
promoting themselves on YouTube and who
did you see get a lot of love that your
slime bash at their boots like who did
who impresses you in the community
sure anybody who do you think is doing a
good job out there
I think parakeet slimes yes a great
influence on people she had a huge line
yep I saw people really love her account
they love her personality who else
Oh Karina Garcia yes she has 8 million
subscribers it was really great to see
her like meeting everyone yep and she's
pretty og right like she's a nice yeah
she was definitely one of the first
slime accounts she's also DIY too
yep and then also I think like everyone
in Slammers alley which is sort of like
the rising Slimers they all gained so
many followers from slime bash it was
really great to see to see that - what
are your friends thinking about this now
in eighth grade vs. sixth grade like
it's a very like just knowing like kids
like it's really interesting you're like
starting to go to another chapter of
your
lessons and like like do they think
slimes not as cool but it's cool that
you're in business like what's that
what's the take right now like our
younger yo are you in are you in a
school where eighth grades the oldest
grade and there's younger kids in this
yes so like do some of the fourth
graders like think you're famous and
want to take selfies like what's
happening in the trenches at school well
the little kids it's really funny they
always are you K through 8 or you I'm 5
4 3 K 3 4 and then K 3 right so like
that that's interesting go ahead so
what's happening with the youngsters do
they um I don't really I mean they're
not really on Instagram yep so but one
time I do receive a really sweet note
from a little fourth grader who asks me
if I wanted to hang out with her one day
make slime which is really nice and but
a lot of my friends at school they don't
like slime I really hate it they think
slime bash is really cool they all went
to the world record so yeah that's how
it's working you know one of things
that's really interesting to me about
this trend and I'm you just brought up
with Garcia I'd like to get your
thoughts on this
the do-it-yourself movement do you think
that slime is going to graduate a lot of
young girls in to being creators in
other areas definitely I think a lot of
people are actually moving to vlogging
like the parakeet slimes who I was
talking about before
she she's now doing school vlogs all the
time and what about soap have you seen
that oh yeah so Connie yeah what do you
what are you seeing with that um ASMR in
general like of course there yeah
there's eating a smarter slimy a smaller
and people are like ASMR is kind of a
large category now so people are
definitely moving towards that - yeah
what what else should parents know about
this think about it entrepreneurship
slime what would some some of your hot
takes well I think the key is that
there's always going to be something
that's right and pair
you don't always have to approve
anything most parents are beginning it
in their households because of the mess
yeah kids make messes yeah I think it's
better to teach them responsible Ness of
making slime make them clean up after
themselves yeah it's a mess but if you
make them clean up versus just saying
gee it's going to be a mess
yeah it's you know you have to temper
what'd you do - what'd you encourage
your kids versus what not do you don't
cut and covers your kids because there's
so there's a domino effect positively
and negative to whatever you do to your
kids I couldn't agree more talk to me
about you talked about marketing and
being an entrepreneur what have you
learned about the current state of
marketing through this adventure of
slime if anything well I've learned a
lot about the influencer world which is
not my you know not my bandwagon that's
the new generation mmm the power of the
generation I mean this this generation
can move the NFL to shut down just with
a couple tweets so it's really
fascinating that in just in a niche of
something to like the new let me go back
please a new superstars are parakeet's
limes versus Taylor Swift like I think
they're both next to each other at slime
bash
I think parakeet would have a larger
line I understand and that's fascinating
I think we all have to understand it
because this is the generation is going
to rule the next world a hundred percent
any questions you have for me you sure
you want to buy the Jets more than
anything professionally can you make
them good a hundred thousand percent
because everything in life stems from
the top Tampa on your radar just random
um Maddie what what should for everybody
who's listening what what should they
know about the slime movement the DIY
move in like just the whole scene um I
think that a lot of people view slime is
like a fad or in a trend but really
there's a large community of people who
are making it and it's now a job for a
ton of people so
what what's been the most surprising
thing in last month in the trends sales
you know any anything stand out to you
like if I'm just trying to siphon some
IP from you on like things that are
happening in the trenches like what's
what's kind of interesting so I like the
flat container thing what else
well now slime acrobatics are actually
becoming a thing so there's something
called slime flippin yep where you take
this line when you flip it and try to
make a big bubble um it's not it's not
really making a bubble it's like doing
tricks with the slide yep so that's the
acrobatics like yeah it's like are you
doing that I'm really bad at it yes
though not really but there are like
people who have made really cool videos
of them flipping slime so it's really
cool to see the new tricks that people
come up with I love it so please lose
that I had a question though at least
I'd love to know your thoughts just in
general you know about the getting the
conventions because one of the things
that we find fascinating or I do is that
the this is one of the first times that
you have this internet world of
influencers and millions of kids around
the world that are actually leaving the
internet coming to meet their
communities I mean this is inspiring
yeah this is happening and has been
happening for the last half decade the
trend of as we live in a digital world
like enhances real life experiences
whether it's as simple as people going
and taking a hike because they want the
photo for their Instagram or I mean look
when vine was popping you know a lot of
the teenybopper boys nash grier and
cameron dallas in these characters they
went on tour and had thirty forty
thousand VidCon gets hundreds of
thousands like this is this has been
going on and will continue to go on and
I do think that there will be whether
it's fads or long trends like look when
your dad and I were growing up baseball
cards were massive then for 20 years
they weren't now there's a bubbling up
again like to your point I do I don't
think slime will be as white hot as it
is right now in perpetuity it will it
will peak in valley but do I think it
got so hot and so at scale that it will
now have cycle
I do I feel like if I if I was
predicting I'm like okay it has another
three years of goodness then it starts
really kind of calming down it's still
happening there's still plenty of people
making but it's not in the zeitgeist
attendance to something like slime bash
Peaks of 50,000 goes down to eight
thousand and six thousand seven years
later if you guys ran it forever and
then it reboots that's what always
happens that's what happens with GI Joe
that's what happens with wrestling
that's what happens with you know
nineties closes that's what's happening
now with Filan tommy hilfiger so i what
I think slime has accomplished that a
lot of other fads don't where they only
have a six month window a nine month
white heat window pencil fighting do
remember pencil fighting did you have
that whenever they [ __ ] yeah yeah so
that was huge for us in six and seventh
grade that wasn't big enough and didn't
sustain long enough that it's coming
back every five seven ten years I do
think slime has that as far as like the
event marketing business I couldn't be
more bullish I couldn't be more bullish
I think what you what you put in the
container of these convention centers
and casinos will change some things have
100 year runs some have you know three
year blips then they come back but yeah
I think I think you I think of it like
Aerosmith and Rolling Stones and like
you know Run DMC like they're gonna you
know once you can establish something it
ebbs and flows but it's always kind of
around absolutely yeah I mean look it's
it's a intense business like it's taxing
right like you can make a lotta you
could build a warehouse in your backyard
if you have the space to make a ton of
slime and sell it through Amazon but
slepping to Daytona and making sure
everything's right like it's you know
it's but the experience is the bit like
look I'm I'm in agreement with your
six-year-old like you know I the thought
that your family's gonna have this
adventure and remember this time
together too is just disproportionately
valuable in my opinion absolutely we do
it all together so it's great oh I have
a question for you Maddie one thing that
I'm very passionate about is what I call
the super premium category of any
product
I'm always most interested in how much
can you actually charge for something
right so for example a big dream of mine
has
been to start a $20 pack of bubble gum
like that's expensive for bubblegum but
it's 20 bucks is achievable for a lot of
people so I've always thought it's an
interesting category what's the most
expensive slime you've seen like what
was the most expensive slime sold at
slime bash or you've seen recently on
Instagram from an influencer has anybody
made something really expensive yet um
well there's 32 ounces are becoming a
really big trend now so no more worded
trends what wordy ounces before that
most people sell in two four and six
ounces and eight ounces yep so 32 bulk
yeah it's really big so um I've seen
people charge as much as $50 for them
what's the most expensive 8 ounce slime
you can think of that you've seen the
last year and a half um probably $17 and
what was that um I believe it was a
butter slime cuz it contained a lot of
days Oh clay which is very expensive
understood and sent so fragrant so I
have a something seems to be like
popping too right yeah there it's very
expensive though so 32 ounce would use a
bottle of scent understood you bring
interesting point I wonder if there's
like you could put real gold flakes in
something or limited edition of only
seven made in there yeah when you get
big enough when your parakeet we did
Brian Anthony like these kind of
characters like you could just say I'm
only making 25 of these here's what I'm
doing with it like I do think look again
I'm using it because it's our context
point upper deck came along and you know
just it was expensive we were paying 50
cents a pack for cards and then it was 2
bucks and I was like that was insanity I
do think that there's an absolute
category for one of them influencers to
take that leap and create a super
premium category and I do think that
there are plenty of people like Maddie
this may sound interesting to you given
that you're in the trenches I do believe
that there is a $50 8 ounce slime to be
sold in the slime community I really do
have an calendar yes some people I've
seen some women are $169 for an advent
calendar what
to calendar so like a an Advent God
confused Gary oh that's the open things
yeah that's what it's called yeah yeah
25 days of slime yeah that's awesome
it's not really like a door you don't
open the doors it's just a giant box
full of 25 signs understood 25 slimes
for a buck what um one hundred and sixty
nine dollars but for 25 slimes yes so
that's pretty good it I mean that's a
good deal in me but I understand the
bulk of it no real and really I'm really
curious if somebody's gonna come out and
make $49 slime in an 8 ounce and say
that the tears of a seal from our part
like there's really like that's the
stuff like or you or one could you know
listen what's amazing about the Internet
is you know is there some if can you add
the water from a creek in your backyard
and because you've been vlogging and
everybody gives a crap about that Creek
like there's so much creativity that is
still yet to be solved there's the media
for the conventions there's the mega
bash ticket which gives people a premium
and if and they always sell out
immediately first yeah how did that go
down your first slime bash sold let's
talk about that event marking its sold
out in 10 you sold 7,000 tickets you
sold 7,000 tickets and how fast will the
first convention sold out their premium
tickets in about eight minutes
and how do you promote it just your what
my Instagram but we had VIP Slimers
which are like the famous influencers so
they really promoted it people wanted to
meet them so they came and bought the
tickets and so did you have to like
learn to negotiate with these people for
their appearance fees or they just want
the exposure or what went down well this
is the first time as everybody was ever
done yeah and they want to meet their
fans they just want to meet their
community so and they're gonna sell a
lot of slime that's right it's sort of
like like a special thing to be a part
of the first-ever slime convention so it
was really cool too so it was a win-win
for everybody I mean they came got to
meet a they sold enough slime that it
was well worth their while before we sat
down you guys were gracious said we have
four tickets to give away how how would
you like to functionally do that do you
want people to follow you on Instagram
and leave a comment that they want the
tickets any any functionality of how we
want to give away these tickets are you
trying to build up any of your other
channels have you started building up
your Twitter yet I don't think you have
a Twitter account yeah
so it's Instagram only for you yeah
mm-hmm so maybe they they can go on here
if they post on your Instagram why don't
we do this
everybody who's listening if you want
tickets to Florida or Chicago it's is it
slime bash calm for details yes cool so
just go to slime bash com2 see the dates
for the details and whether it's Chicago
or Florida why don't you go to and
what's your Instagram handled
slime by Maddy right slime by Maddy
right yes okay ra e yes cool
go to her Instagram account and leave in
the comment section hashtag Gary sent me
hashtag Gary sent me and then I'll let
them figure out how who they're gonna
pick an Al and what yeah sure please who
is this voice from the outside tell
everybody
Denise yes yep yes yes
yes I understand sure yes yes yes
well not to upset you for what you setup
I in it tremendously but I do not
believe that people should do things
that they're uncomfortable with for the
sake of what's the right tactic
it's listen it's a big jump you know you
have to I'd only understand how to
deploy empathy right it's my core when
you're an eighth grade girl and you're
not interested in documenting your life
even though it's disproportionally
helpful for the ambition you know I have
to I have to be empathetic I see but but
but you'll you'll you'll appreciate this
but even that like as much as it would
be remarkably good for the business for
you sitting down and having those
brainstorm meetings you know how
interesting it would be to see the video
of how you came up with the idea for the
largest slime in the world after it has
hundreds of millions of views like
that's what I'm doing I'm documenting
I've got content that I'm going to show
in 19 years that proved that this wasn't
a mistake that this was strategy and so
yes it's valuable and the other thing
Maddie I will tell you you will
unbelievably god-willing love to watch
these videos of you going through this
process with your daughter one day I
promise you that I'm devastated that I
don't have videos or I don't have a
picture I do not have a single picture
of me at a baseball card job I don't
either
and that destroys my soul so I will say
made one thing to think about which is
hard to think about at this age is how
awesome it's gonna be to have these
videos to look back on and one thing you
guys could consider is documenting them
and if you're not comfortable not
releasing them and maybe releasing them
later they're good to have in a lot of
ways so that's one thing you may want to
think but I do think like if you don't
want it out listen we have to be
empathetic like if you don't want them
out there because you don't want your
friends critiquing it like in eighth
grade [ __ ] eighth grade you care
about your friends opinions a lot no
matter how entrepreneurial and how
awesome your pair
that's life and I think it's dangerous
to push people into things that don't
come natural to them but no question
you're a hundred percent right
documenting the content is is just
valuable as heck Maddie you know um yeah
I definitely agree I mean I think I do
like to document my business life more
than my personal make sense but how do
you think about the other social media
platforms actually let me let me let me
step out for a second from all of this
what's going on in school in eighth
grade in your class what are the core
social networks that people are using
right now um Instagram and snapchat
that's it I mean my friends watch
YouTube but they don't have YouTube
channels understood consuming YouTube
not creating consuming and creating on
Instagram and snapchat yes and if I said
a hundred percent of the activities
between Instagram and snapchat is it
8020 Instagram um 5050 I'd say most
people have Instagram and snapchat I
don't have snapchat but I know that most
of my class has Instagram so 8020
probably Twitter no no nobody no I don't
think anyone in my class is Twitter yeah
and Facebook's like for your dad yeah
yeah I would never consider going to
that boring place no how many what
percentage of class are creating videos
for YouTube um there's only one person
in my class who's really creating
actually now - okay what about podcasts
is anybody listening to podcasts um I'm
not sure
understood I don't know okay anything
else interesting anything else popping
um
[Music]
tick tock yeah but it's mostly for my
class it's mostly like a meme to them
yep and it's mostly like a joke it's not
really no one really makes tic TOCs for
fun and does everybody realize it's like
old musically like is there yeah
standing and it's like
more people on musically like three
years ago yes my class loved musically
yep and for that reason is there a
little love for tick tock is like a
reminiscing thing um I think so I mean I
- yeah I think so
gosh I have to get an account there is
basically it wasn't I had a couple of
funny music plays myself ah
matter how you I really appreciate guys
being on the show um it's it's really
it's really a show I've been waiting to
do mainly because it's just so much of
what I believe and and care about and
it's super impressive and I'm so excited
for your success Maddie and like the
events business is just like super
interesting to me like it's just so much
good and like I'm always here to help if
I can
thank you yeah any last words thank you
for having me on the show you're welcome
yeah and they am what you're doing is
great and yeah we love any kind of
feedback obviously Thanks never stop
learning
cool thanks for listening everybody you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]